with the launch of jetpack and the KTX
libraries we've made Android development
even sweeter in Collin but our haps rely
on more than just the Android libraries
as app writers and library maintainer
there's a lot you can do to be Kotlin
friendly first you should update your
existing code to follow the interrupt
guide then you can start building Kotla
specific api's this video will cover the
Interop guide which covers best
practices for writing code in the java
programming language to support Collin
it has four main Interop suggestions
first Kotlin is all about null safety to
support this in the java programming
language add the annotations nullable
and none know everywhere in your public
API Collin will use these to make your
API Noll safe now what happens if you
don't
well Kotlin makes what's called a
platform type it's a hisin type that can
be null or non null and it leads to
heisenbugs and null pointer exceptions
when you do use annotations Collin will
make your API is null safe fixing the
null pointer exceptions getters and
setters are important for interrupt
Collin requires they follow the beam
style get name set name is active set
active when you do this
Collin will elevate them to properties
so they can be used naturally next
Collin add support for lambdas and you
can interrupt with them by using single
abstract methods examples of single
abstract methods are runnable and
callable when defining your API make
sure to put your single abstract method
parameters last then Kotlin developers
can make full use of lambdas and finally
collet has some different keywords and
it's important to avoid name conflicts
if you do provide a function called is
developers can still call it by saying
backtick is backtick but let's be honest
that is not a good look for a full list
of keywords
check out the interrupt guide to help
support Interop we've added tooling to
Android studio 3.2 introducing lint
checks that will warn you for all
Interop issues to use them enable the
interoperability group in Gradle another
tool for colin is daca if you're
generating documentation with the
Javadoc tool you can migrate to using
dakka dakka will generate your
documentation and it supports
of languages there's a lot you can do to
make sure your existing code is collin
friendly in this video I covered how to
follow the inter up guide and we'll
cover how to make Collin specific api's
in a later video thanks for watching see
you again next time
[Music]